all right so let's start with the first
one then
which which is the first one you want to
start with do you want to want to go in
order to start with this one
this is the one where it was just a
strange story i i admit it at times it
was quite
quite hot but then it was also really
weird really really weird so i i mean
like also so there's this girl who's a
ghost
but she's then not a ghost i think she's
taking medicine to go invisible
and then she's like sucking him off in
the class and no one can see him suck
no one but she's invisible but he's not
so why is his dick invisible
this is gonna sound really strange this
was a very confusing plot
oh yeah so if you care about reading the
dojins we're gonna be
spoiling it i guess if you care about
the
this was plots this was like for every
like in this one at least for every like
one moment that i was like oh that's hot
it would literally do 10 other things so
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah honestly i i i cuz after you've
read the
everything because i only i thought
you're just going to read a few chapters
i read a few chapters of joey and then
when you said you read everything i went
back to just completely finish
everything as well right i feel like
there's just a complete 180 at the end
as well where it starts going into this
other backstory i'm like no no yeah
that that author tends to do that with
everything he writes there was just like
moments in there when i had to write
down
it was like this [ __ ] is mad in cell
these isn't that most doji
because there was like oh these girls
are wearing skirts they're such
[ __ ] and i'm like all right these
feminines
all right all right okay jeez i'm like i
dare you i know what i'm getting myself
into
uh i mean look i mean look at the main
character he's just he's like okay okay
i guess before he gets into it joey do
you want to explain why yeah why did he
watch this why
why did you choose this one okay so
literally
i'll admit this was the part where i was
like [ __ ] i don't know what to do for
the third one
okay uh but but uh i like everything
uh by akatsuki mito who's like this
artist so honestly any one of his could
have been on this list
right but i figured like probably the
least weird one for connor
would be this one the least weird at
least
i feel like this is not the least
there's a few other i mean i
it's not that bad no at least weird out
of his works
oh okay yeah yeah i mean like the other
two are ones that i actually really
enjoy
yeah that like immediately came off the
top of my head you know the one thing
that i i wish they would just chill out
with on dogens is just how fast [ __ ]
escalates
it goes from like ooh to like gangbang
in the showers within like four pages at
times
and i'm like hold on hold on hold on
let this boy chill her out a little bit
let him play some video games be like
[ __ ] i just [ __ ] you know like damn
i don't know why you're suggesting that
because you're probably going to skip
over it yeah i know i know but it's it's
just like oh god okay
oh god we're [ __ ] i'll just yeah just
like give me a warning i
actually had like out of everyone i had
the most trouble following this story
this was really
confusing i thought it was like a really
simple story and then like the last
chapter here so i'm just like
what is going on right now because i'm
i'm [ __ ] stupid can you explain the
basic
supremacy of the story from what i
said it's from what i understand this
guy this was
okay so again you're not found i want to
spoil the thing because you find out
more earlier on but we'll start from the
start you just kind of find this guy
kind of like a normal cell kind of i
mean something like that
you know wants to get revenge on all the
women around him and then a girl
transfers into the school
who then immediately just stops
so only he can see her but no one else
can see her
so she gives him glasses or something
that
makes yeah she she gives him some
glasses
that make all the clothes see through so
he's just
looking at all these naked girls while
while being sucked off by this invisible
girl even though no girl can see yeah
so this girl immediately starts sucking
him off right right away and then
i hate it when they do this when they
refer to the characters when they refer
to themselves in the third person
to me i'm like stop that what is that is
that is that what they did yeah they did
that in the
only in the first scene and i was like
oh god please don't make this a constant
thing
she's like calling herself her name
which is charlotte i think yeah oh yeah
yeah she's like charlotte is happy and
i'm like yeah yeah yeah she calls
herself third person
um admittedly it's been a while since i
read this
yeah i was hoping you could bring more
context into it
okay but i remember the reason why i
picked this one is because
it literally has every tag i guess
that's what i enjoy about it like you
get the best of i was about to say both
worlds
everywhere everywhere every multiverse
there's a lot
and so he [ __ ] he rocks the the ghost
blow job and apparently no one else can
see yeah
even though he's like clearly nuts yeah
this guy is literally nutting he's like
are you telling me like are you okay
yeah like as if no one would notice that
you're you know come on yeah
to be honest that sounds [ __ ]
hilarious it's hard to believe that this
is attractive because
yeah there's there's no way i could be
like oh that that's hot that could be me
like no it could never ever be me
and i not that i would ever want to go
sucking i don't want casper sucking me
off
yeah but you know it's kind of you know
what i mean
but basically like the first the first
chapter just kind of reminded me of like
some
like some porn spin off of bunnygirl's
empire right yeah well
you know you know where he's in the
library and you see my sees my for the
first time and no one else to see him
this is basically just that you know
this is bad if it was r18 yeah yeah yeah
exactly also i know i've watched hentai
so i know this [ __ ] exists but there was
one
piece of dialogue as well where like the
bully girls who are like attractive or
whatever
the gals all right oh uh you know
they ask him for money and that's so
inexcusable that in return
he's gonna [ __ ] them that's how he's
gonna get back at them yeah and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this watching
like what it's insane
okay now he becomes horny casper the
ghost
he goes
so then what happens is is that uh he
the girl this charlotte ghost girl then
is like well
don't worry homie i got you and starts
like drugging the other people in the
class that make them horny
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and then she
introduces like new power-ups this is
like the fastest
that's what i'm saying man like it's
every time and then he's like hold up
but now you can drug them
and then i'll give you invisibility
drugs and it's like but you only got 30
minutes and then he starts [ __ ] like
the whole school
and then and then they find out and then
they don't care and then they carry on
[ __ ]
and then this just goes insanity and
literally the whole school is being
[ __ ] by this guy within like
i'm literally 10 minutes into the story
and this is what's going on i can't i
can't think
what is happening which girl is which i
don't know which they all have the same
hairstyle
wait a minute is this girl robin wait
which one's the which one's the guy no
what is happening it was at this point
where like you know you know when
there's like so many girls that all of
them just start blending in together
yeah
and you're just like i don't even know
who you're [ __ ] anymore you know
right
like you know and then where the [ __ ]
did this willy wonka candy come from
where everyone's everyone's just [ __ ]
horny now where does it come from
where's the backstory to that
and then later on we find out that uh
the main girl who he wanted to [ __ ] the
whole time yeah uh
was some poor homeless girl that he was
speaking to in the start oh the student
council girl yeah that he got made fun
of for talking to
and then the girl wishes that they never
met or he
mentions that he never and then his dog
his doll comes to life and that's the
one he's [ __ ] then she brings the
drugs
what is going on that's that's what
confused me it was that chapter where
the door starts talking and i'm just
like have i just
skipped over a chapter because it just
this is literally like you lord of the
rings when you miss like one page you're
like hold up did i just miss the whole
i don't miss the whole story the whole
point is i didn't go back 20 pages
it feels like i just got a shyamalan
twist without having a charm on movie
yeah
every page is like i can't keep up with
it i'm just like what is going on but
like there'll be like two moments on
like that's hot
but then what is going on okay okay what
i didn't understand was okay so
was the main girl just was she wearing a
wig the entire time
was that the twist
he shows up at this house and he's just
like what's the girl's name again
like charlotte charlotte and it's it's
it's a girl with black hair and then
charlotte [ __ ] runs away and she
starts putting her on a wig right yeah
yeah i mean am i following this
correctly wait what i don't know
this was like the second to last chapter
right i thought it was just like
i you know what i i honestly got very
confused i'm not gonna lie
there's multiple times i reread this
ending like four times and i still
didn't understand what was happening
and then like they they just pull like
you know he he literally
it's just the the sheer like
how it just changes like completely yeah
it literally ends on like a gang bang
and then the next panel it's like
you can just you could hear the anahana
music playing it's like but really
there's a sad backstory as to why he's
[ __ ] everything
oh get the [ __ ] out of here what is this
i don't give a [ __ ]
no i'm not gonna lie i i chose this one
because i knew
you guys would react like this because
it's so ridiculous that i just love it
like you know that shonen trope where
like the villain gets defeated and then
after the villain's defeated you finally
see his backstory
that's like that that doesn't belong in
a hentai you know
you can't just yeah you can't just [ __ ]
a girl and then just show her backstory
after she gets [ __ ] okay
like i need this context before the
[ __ ] happens
it's like it's like putting a backstory
in the middle of a fight right he's just
like why now why now
you couldn't wait until afterwards i'm
not gonna lie some of these are blend no
it's blending into my head this is the
one and it just ends how does this one
end
it ends with this random [ __ ] side
story of someone average
with the marriage like what is happening
and like i don't i didn't
recognize any of these characters
characters look the same it wasn't even
the main [ __ ] character
but they just [ __ ] they just [ __ ] for
some reason even though he's just
cheated right before he's like wedding
day or something
he like cheats right before his wedding
day like the whole story is like they're
a fan club of him
i think yeah fan club of the ghost that
[ __ ]
like the the main protagonist the incel
guy
they make a fan club of him in the side
story but i don't recognize any of these
characters no
no and then two of them are getting
married and it's not it's not even the
main girl
it's a different girl and then he cheats
on her
right before the day of and then there's
a whole scene of does anyone object to
the marriage
and they were like i do
it's like
there's so much [ __ ] happening that i'm
like what do i even begin to critique
because there's just way too much [ __ ]
going on it's like someone
he's he literally pulled up every genre
and he was like a bet yeah like i'm
gonna get that's exactly what you do
it's like is there is there a genre
where it's like you know uh
shout out at the wedding no that could
be a tag yeah it probably is
[Laughter]
that's that is this tag it's just
stopped the count right because he's
[ __ ] so many girls now
i can't even count how many girls he's
[ __ ]
like i said on the hentai episode you
know there has to be some kind of story
in there
and there was more oh now you care about
story huh i and hint i i do yeah i need
a little bit of story
which is why this is one of the time
when some of them it might shock you
that i enjoy later
but like this one was just like what the
[ __ ] is happening
it's a dumbass story [ __ ] keeps getting
weirder and weirder
no not in a funny way like yeah one
hentai where people start shooting each
other and there's dubstep
there's no dub steps going dubstep would
have gone great with some of these
things oh yeah yeah
i wish there was a built-in like dubstep
you could have just gone on to youtube
honestly this is the kind of yeah it's
literally the kind of doji but i put on
skrillex in the background and it'll be
well paced like
honestly like reading this i i feel like
my boner got whiplash
yeah with the amount of [ __ ]
you're just like gotta work out after
that
every time you you're like i'm into this
it's like no no no no no okay
it's like you start getting into it nope
new tag okay well i guess i'll just nope
okay new tag okay and i'm just like okay
what is the theme to this what was
what was the authentication what was the
video what was the author trying to say
this is literally what tags you want yes
this is what this is it's terrible it's
[ __ ] true no to me it needed like
it needed okay this is going to sound so
[ __ ] pretentious it needs something
to connect all the dots
right no i honestly i'm gonna agree with
you oh my [ __ ] god are we agreeing on
something connor
my [ __ ] god this fellow trash tastes
first this felt like just
ten dojins that have been like let's
just [ __ ] ram them into one
we got these sexy girls that i don't
want to redraw or in different ways like
you know you know what this felt like
this felt like it was like if the mcu
had one recurring character in every
movie
right but then it was just like it was
it was one continuous narrative
but it's because every movie genre is so
[ __ ] different
you just don't know what the [ __ ]
going on you can't follow anything
it's like playing all the mcu movies at
once yeah